bien sûr oui bien sûr il faut pas
hésiter à demander de l'aide mais moi
c'est pas mais à mes collègues que je
dois me donner c'est à mon patron c'est
plus rapide c'est plus efficace et il
est surtout beaucoup plus disponible
mais ce qu'il vous aide
[Rires]
[Musique]
j'ai perdu beaucoup d'argent même
supporter caution il y a longtemps pour
quelqu'un j'ai perdu
oui oui j'étais caution à la banque
parce que c'est quelqu'un
cette personne j'avais confiance et j'ai
toujours confiance mais bon j'étais
obligé de payer à sa place et j'avais
pas bien lu toutes les lignes de contrat
et j'ai payé beaucoup d'argent vous êtes
toujours copines bien sûr mais tu as un
fou toi
vraiment beaucoup là ça m'a pris
longtemps ça m'a vraiment
tu vois c'est un amour c'est d'être
copain encore parce que moi j'ai un mec
je crois que c'était mon pote et que il
me met dans la merde financièrement je
dois payer pour lui je pense qu'il m'a
trahi moi je dis ok d'accord il m'a pas
trahi il savait
[Applaudissements]
mais je tiens à dire pour la suite des
événements que je n'aime pas
particulièrement donner de l'argent par
contre c'est perdu de toute façon c'est
perdu tu préfères dire je te prête pas
je te donne et
ça m'agace dans l'idée que rembourser
qui peut pas alors moi je peux aussi du
principe jamais je vous prête d'argent
parce que c'est le meilleur moyen de se
fâcher
quand on me demande tu dis vraiment je
te dis nous rentrons pas là dedans ça va
ça va ça va pourrir notre amitié je vous
le donne au commencement de votre
carrière
quand c'est qui que vous aviez pas
d'argent et qu'il y avait une période de
vache mec est-ce que vous avez emprunté
de l'argent près d'amis est-ce que ou
parfois vous avez dit c'est dur j'arrive
pas à tout ça emprunter
tu sais j'ai ah parce qu'après c'est une
tanière
mais j'en ai prêté beaucoup moi
c'est son problème
c'est ce qu'on vous demande souvent de
l'argent
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
un vrai problème et je vous appelle
voilà on se parle comme ça gentiment et
tout genre vous me prêtez rien fait
par exemple salut Sophie ça va ma chérie
tu vas bien
non mon mec ça va à peu près mais j'ai
un peu des petits soucis de quoi
j'hésitais un peu à t'en parler
à l'idée
si je suis là si je dois t'aider je
t'aiderai oui même pour de l'argent par
exemple
j'avais un problème d'argent
ça va pas d'accord
qu'on se connaît pas tant que ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que j'ose pas
ce que je peux faire je peux te rendre
service j'appelle ton mec pour lui
demander pour toi
je vais te dire
je vais pas te dire pourquoi je vais pas
le faire parce que je sais comment ça va
se passer je vais donner 100 euros
je te le dis tu veux que je te dis si
elle promet de garder le secret
parce que ça sortira ça sortira on s'en
bat et ça me foutra dans la merde oui ça
sortira et vous pouvez aller dans quel
cas alors
franchement quoi je sais pas à quel
moment vraiment voilà vous vous dites là
je ne peux pas vivre
de l'argent
nous n'avons jamais pris de l'argent non
non on peut pas on peut pas parce que si
on vous fait une reconnaissance
je l'ai fait je l'ai fait il y a très
longtemps je vous disais je l'ai fait il
y a très longtemps
sur les grosses sommes c'est compliqué
de préparer en galère et que tu dois lui
prêter 200 balles pour faire les courses
bien évidemment que tu prêtes aux gens
tout le temps et tu donnes c'est perdu
avec ma voiture
je connais pas ton tout ça
et vous prêtez vos maisons pour les
vacances votre piscine tu commences à me
faire chier
[Applaudissements]
et c'est toi qui m'appelle je te vois là
je suis à l'antenne les 19h30 32 c'est
Gad Elmaleh ça va mon frère
mais je suis en direct
je suis en train de te parler
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ça va mon frérot
minutes
[Rires]
est-ce que tu
[Applaudissements]
fais
changer
[Rires]
tu peux faire quelque chose parce que je
alors tu me laisses le temps de de la
pause pour voir ce que je peux faire
qu'est-ce que je kiffe ces histoires je
suis grave le bail j'adore non mais tu
sais je vais te dire je t'aurais
franchement je t'ai demandé de l'argent
dans plusieurs fois
non mais c'est vrai
et on a on a pour principe de ne jamais
se prêter d'argent vraiment jamais
j'aime en tout cas
il y a une théorie qu'il faut que tu
connais vraiment
vérifier elle est vraiment si tu prête
de l'argent un ami tu perds l'argent et
l'ami bravo il a raison
[Applaudissements]
et l'ami tandis que si tu lui prépares
tu perds que l'ami
c'est quoi au moins pour aller
je t'explique pourquoi j'ai sauté sur
l'occasion pour t'appeler parce que j'ai
un pote il m'appelle beaucoup en ce
moment et je sais qu'il regarde ton
émission ouais donc comme ça il a sa
réponse voilà
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je t'aime mon frère je t'embrasse très
fort en bas
je t'aime mon frérot je te vois pas
de l'argent tu perds l'argent et l'ami
il a raison
on se connaît pas tant que ça
je vais je vais te dire mais il faut que
tu m'oublies moi
c'est une glue là-bas je te le dis
arrête avec cet argent ça va tout pourri
hein d'accord c'est bon ça va Gigi
qu'est-ce que tu veux toi chérie
je vais faire le tour et je dis à qui je
prêterai de l'argent ou pas
pas tout de suite
non Géraldine
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que c'est Bernard le plus riche
qui est le plus riche d'ici pour vous
êtes des grands malades
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi le plus riche
mais je pense pas
je confirme c'est bien plus riche
j'aimerais bien je pense pas
sérieusement
avec une piscine Ramatuelle avec une
piscine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]